in a startups life there is no single
day that will not bring a new challenge
so what are sort of the common
challenges that students will face as
they're on their path to monetization
nirvana there are three main ones
acquisition retention and earning
acquisition this is not an easy step how
can you put your product in front of
enough users so some of them 4% or less
will convert and pay for it in many
cases you should focus and narrow this
search less is more here if you can
focus on a niche segment in the market
you will get a better chance to reach
the users who are willing to try a
product second exciting your audience
surprise them with your quality it's
easy to say how to do nevertheless you
want to do it
you wish to invest in the retention of
your users and a known way to do it is
by creating wonderful experience users
love quality and simplicity third
earning in commerce make it easy for
them to pay in mobile e-commerce there
are lots of forms with lots of fields
we'll go into more details on how to
reduce the friction in that process a
bit later in app purchases charge the
right users with the right offer at the
right time
there are many user segments and each
deserves its own customized offering for
example in a mobile gaming app 5% of the
users drove 95 percent of the revenue so
it was a smart move to improve the
offering for these 5% ads do your best
to use ads that enhance the user
experience